نحن مستعدون لمبادله بايلكورود مقابل
عضويه الناتو والرد الروسي لا يتاخر الغرب
يتوسل لاوكرانيا لمواجهه مباشره مع الدب
الروسيه
ضربات اوكرانيه تغلق مطارات موسكو والكريم
لن يرد لتعلن كيا حاله الطوارئ القصوى
تكشف تكتيك بوتين الخطير الذي افشل الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد والاوكران يضعون اللمسات
الاخيره لكسر الحظر الروسي في البحر
الاسود فهل يفي بوتين بوعده ويشعل الحرب
في احشاء البحار مهلا مهلا لمن هذا
الاسطول المرعب نعم كيم يشرف على اول هجوم
بحري
والاكواست ترفض مقترح المجلس الانتقالي
والمجلس يعلن اطلاق سراح بازوم لكن بشرط
واحد وارد كان يهدد السويد من جديد فما
الذي يجري وبعد تركيا ها هي ايران تحبس
المياه عن العراق
الناتو يتوسل لزينسكي ان تود دول الغربيه
يضعون ثقه لهم في الكفه الاوكرانيه
ويطلقون مقترحاتهم يمنه ويسرى لربما يقبل
الاوكران باحدها ولكن في كييف اذن من طين
واخرى من عجيج فالعاصمه الاوكرانيه تتجاهل
طروحات الغرب واخرها مقترح التنازل على
جزء من اراضيها مقابل السلام واليوم ها هو
زيلينس كيارود بقوله ان كياف مستعده
لمبادله بيلجورود مقابل عضويه النيتو تنتى
دمك خفيف قوي دمك شربات يا واد لا ننسى ان
بي مقاطعه روسيه يا اصدقاء في المقابل جاء
الرد الروسي سريعا وعلى لسان صاحب الردود
اللاذعه متحدثه بوتين ماريا
على ما يبدو تناول جرعه زائده من المخدرات
لتاتي النصيحه
حيث اكد ضابط الاستخبارات الامريكي
المتقاعد طوني شفر ان الناتو ان قرر
الصدام مع روسيا بشكل مباشر في اوكرانيا
سيخسر المواجهه وانه لا طريق للحل سوى
المفاوضات فهل وصلت الرساله نعم لقد وصلت
الرساله وها هو الغرب يتوصل لاوكرانيا
لتشن هجمات مباشره وجها لوجه ضد القوات
الروسيه لكن كييف لا تملك الموارد اللازمه
لذلك بحسب صحيفه الايكونوميست وهنا ياتي
الدعم الغربي اللازم لتلك المواجهه وذلك
بطائره اف 16 من الدنمارك وهولندا ولكن
وزير الدفاع
قال ان بلاده اشترطت على كييف استخدام
مقاتله اف 16 التي ستزودها بها فقط على
اراضي اوكرانيا ليعلن ضابط المخابرات
الامريكيه السابق
ان توريد الطائره المقاتله اف 16 لن يكون
قادرا على تغيير موقف اوكرانيا التي تعاني
من خسائر فادحه وسيتم اسقاطها في غضون شهر
الى هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد والذي لم يكد
يولد حتى مات لتكشف صحيفه ويل جورنال عن
السبب بقولها ان الانظمه الروسيه الحديثه
التي تساعد على زرع متفجره عن بعد اعقت
الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاده بشكل كبير
واوضحت الصحيفه في مقال النشرات ان الجيش
الروسي قادر على زرع حقول الالغام على
مسافه تتراوح ما بين خمسه الى 15 كيلومتر
لافته الى ان هذا الاسلوب واحد من عشرات
التكتيكات الروسيه لتجهيز حقول الالغام
والان الى الميدان الذي يشتعل بالنيران
حيث اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه احباط هجوم جديد
شانه نظام
استهدفت العاصمه موسكو وتم اسقطهما في
ضواحي العاصمه وهناك اصيب شخصان على الاقل
عندما سقط حتم مسيره اوكرانيه بينما تم
تعليق رحلات الوصول والمغادره في مطار
فونكوفو في موسكو بشكل مؤقت كما قيود على
حركه الطيران في مطار
بالعاصمه الروسيه لتفيد الوكاله الروسيه
للنقل الجوي بتغيير مسارات نحو 50 طائره
بسبب القيود المفروضه على مطارات موسكو
فيما تم استئناف الرحلات بعد ساعات من ذلك
الهجوم وفقا لوكاله طاس وها هو المصدر
يتحدث امامكم من جانبها افادت الوكاله
الروسيه للنقل الجوي بتغيير مسارات نحو 50
طائره بسبب القيود المفروضه على مطارات
موسكو
رحلات الجويه التي علقت بعد تحطم او علقت
بعد تحطم طائره مسيره اوكرانيه فوق منطقه
موسكو وليس ذلك فحسب بل وكشف مصدر رسمي
اوكراني ان القوات الاوكرانيه تقدمت
جنوبيه باكموت وحررت ثلاثه كيلومترات
مربعه اخرى خلال الاسبوع الماضي وهنا حان
وقت الرد الروسي حيث دمرت القوات الجويه
الروسيه بضربه صاروخ دقيقه قطارا محملا
بالاسلحه الغربيه في محطه
بمقاطعه دنيبروبيترو فاس وسط اوكرانيا في
ضربه ثانيه من هذا النوع خلال اسبوع
والعهده على المصدر كما هو في الموقع
الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه بينما تم اعلان
حاله الطوارئ القصوى
ومظاهر الاحتفال بعيد الاستقلال للعام
الثاني على التوالي وذلك وسط تهديدات
باستهداف واسع النطاق للاراضي الاوكرانيه
ليقتصر الاحتفال على معرض للاسلحه الروسيه
المدمره لكن وبرغم ان الهجوم بوثيره ابطا
من مكانه تامله كياف فانها تؤكد ان قوتها
تحقق تقدما بوتيره ثابته خاصه في الجبهه
الشرقيه واعلنت انها استعادت السيطره على
ثلاثه كيلومترات مربع جنوبي باخموت خلال
الاسبوع الماضي اما في الجبهه الجنوبيه
فيبدو المشهد مغايرا لما تسعى اليه القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تحول منذ ايام شق الصف
القوات الروسيه لمحاوله الوصول الى بحر
ازوف ومن رائحه البارودي ننتقل الى معارك
الامعاء الخاويه حيث نقلت صحيفه
النائب وزير الاقتصاد الاوكراني
قوله ان اوكرانيا تضع اللمسات الاخيره على
خطط مع شركه تامين عالميا لتغطيه نقل
الحبوب من والى موانئها على البحر الاسود
فهل نشهد تنفيذ بوتين لوعوده باستهداف
السفن التي ستمر في البحر الاسود
الاحداث والتطورات اشرف زعيم كوريا
على اختبار صواريخ كروز الاستراتيجيه
وذكرت وكاله الانباء الكوريه ان كيم زارا
اسطولا بحريا المتمركزا على الساحل الشرقي
لتفقد الاختبار على سفينه حربيه ياتي ذلك
بالتزامن مع بدء كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مناورات عسكريه اليوم
اعتبرت
استعدادا منسول و واشنطن لشن حرب نوويه
عليها الى النيجر حيث رفضت مجموعه دول غرب
افريقيا ايكوس خطه الفتره الانتقاليه التي
اقترحها قائد الانقلاب عبد الرحمن تياني
لمده ثلاث سنوات موقف ايكوس جاء بعض
مغادره وفد المجموعه عاصمه النيجر التي
عقد فيها لقاءات وصفها بالمهمه شملت
الرئيس المحتجزه محمد بازون وقائد
الانقلاب عبد الرحمن تياني وتزامرت هذه
اللقاءات مع تظاهر الاف النيجيريين في وسط
العاصمه مرددين شعارات معاديه لكل من
فرنسا ودول غرب افريقيا فيما ذكرت مطلعه
ان المجلس الانتقالي في النيجر اعلن
استعداده للافراج عن الرئيس المخلوع محمد
بازوم مقابل رفع دول ايكواس العقوبات عن
النيجر قال الرئيس التركي رجبتايب اردوغان
ان موقف بلاده بين انضمام السويد الى حلف
الناتو سيكون مغيرا في حال استمرار
الاعتداءات على المقدسات الاسلاميه دون
سابق انذار حبست ايران المياه المتدفقه
الى العراق عبر نهر الزاب الاسفل لتزيد من
تفقم ازمه المياه التي يعانيها العراقيون
في وقت يواجهون فيه خطر التصحر والجفاف مع
تراجع حصتهم من المياه نتيجه السدود التي
شيدتها ايران وتركيا على نهر دجله والفرات
[موسيقى]